eine sehr anstrengende debatte läuft
hier in deutschland wirklich in
endlosschleife was darf satire kommt
immer wieder 18 mal drauf archäologen
haben gerade im neandertal diese
höhlenmalerei gefunden
aktuelles beispiel ist die diskussion
über einen podcast der kollegen so mundt
schröder beim rbb über die wortwahl
einzelne passagen die jetzt auch nicht
meinem ganz persönlichen geschmack
entsprechen darf man nicht nur streiten
sondern man muss sogar streiten es
überhaupt gesund und bringt garantiert
mehr als aus dem netz nehmen oder jedes
mal entschuldigung fordern gernot
hassknecht all people mahnt zu mehr
gelassenheit
die subtile medienkritik mit gernot
hassknecht reden wir mal über die
grenzen des humors oder wie mario barth
sagen würde
kennste grenzte kanzel culture gibt's
überhaupt fakt ist zwar falsch und
idiotisch lisa eckert von diesem
hamburger literatur festival auszuladen
und wie blöd sind bitte die typen bei
der deutschen forschungsgemeinschaft die
dieter nuhrs video gelöscht haben
ich dachte so forscher haben abi und da
geht es nun um die frage ob ich alle
nummern von den beiden privat gut findet
privat finde ich auch die heute show
kacke ob er von irgendwas muss man ja
leben wenn einer die arschlöcher von
rosamunde pilcher nie buchen weil man
angeblich zu klein ist kenntlichkeit ist
vor allem ein kampfbegriff der rechten
als gäbe es nur linke spaßbremsen und
humor standgerichte kurzer reminder
neulich ein wdr kinderchor in einer
offensichtlichen satire das hier
gesungen hat
da haben vor allem rechte die sprengung
des wdr gefordert und der intendant
musste sich in canossa entschuldigen was
er leider auch getan hat
viele die damals hass mails an singende
grundschüler geschickt haben waren im
fall eckert plötzlich führende
verfechter der kunstfreiheit was für
eine verlogene schweizer vorschlag alle
einfach mal mehr aushalten oder
umschalten geht auch und was hat tiere
angeht zwei grundsätzliche hinweise
nicht alles was im fernsehen läuft ist
angst zu 1 zu gemeint wirklich mandant
das stilmittel ironie gamma google da
sagt man was obwohl man das gegenteil
meint es kompliziert und manche humor
schaffende spielen auf der bühne eine
sogenannte rolle ich zum beispiel bin
schauspieler ich spiele den cholerischen
irren nur eigentlich bin ich ein
fröhlicher hesse und es total nett geld
jetzt schon auf sony jetzt hast du mir
den tricks
die subtile medienkritik mit gernot
hassknecht ja it-service bruns weiß ich
spreche mit jürgen wie kann ich ihnen
weiterhelfen haben immer versucht das
gerät aus und wieder einzuschalten hat
nichts gebracht verstehe
probieren sie doch mal den kanal der
heute show auf youtube zu abonnieren
genau und im zweifel wo ich auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung